hello everyone my name is bradley and
today i'm going to share some pretty
cool news with you my team and i have
launched a second channel some sub for
experts and if on this channel for a
whole year i've talked about how to
protect yourself and your data in the
online jungle then on the second channel
well you're going to find information
for those who already professionals
maybe lawyers compliance managers heads
of companies from the field of fintech
and crypto maybe information for those
who are interested in biometric user
identification technologies as well as
kyc kyb aml and also countering online
fraud
[Music]
now we hope that this channel will form
a great community of professionals with
whom we can share our experience and
also use cases that we've worked on
maybe discuss new fintech technologies
and changes in legislation and in
general we'll talk about what really
worries experts and people from the
industry now this channel was hosted by
my colleague and very good friend tony
he's the chief legal officer at some sub
and he's an all-round great guy
but i suppose the big question here is
what are you going to see on the second
channel well number one we're going to
provide you with interviews with world
experts in big money for example right
now on the channel you can actually
follow the link in the description and
watch the first interview with graham
barrow financial crime fighter and a
long-standing celebrity in the money
laundering world now he took part in the
dansk bank story this is one of the most
high profile investigations worth over
234 billion us dollars i'll stress this
was the largest money laundering scandal
in the history of the eu
furthermore on some sub for experts tony
will do an expert analysis without the
formalities for example in the near
future we'll talk about open banking
about corporate registries and also
about self-sovereign identity solutions
if this sounds like something that's
relevant to you then for the link in the
description and watch the first video
don't forget to subscribe as well
farewell